vous écoutez l'interview politique
d'europe 1 il n'y aura pas semble-t-il
de couple fillon bayrou pour la
présidentielle et bien justement fabien
namias vous recevez ce matin françois
bayrou président du modem et maire de
pau bonjour françois bayrou bonjour
françois fillon est il comme il l'a
affirmé hier dans ses voeux le candidat
de la droite et du centre
tout le monde peut prendre les tickets
qu'il veut mais ça n'est pas la question
la question assez comme ça qui s'est
présenté en tout cas la question avec
françois fillon
c'est que il a été élue et choisie par
une compétition interne qu'on appelle
primaire j'ai toujours été contre les
primaires parce que ça rend les
candidats prisonnier d'un camp or le
président de la république qui doit
dépasser les camps et vous voyez que
c'est là qu'on est dans l'ambiguïté est
donc un certain nombre de gens disent
françois fillon ne doit pas bouger un
millimètre de son programme
autrement dit c'est à prendre ou à
laisser
or si on dit aux français aux millions
de français qui s'interrogent
aujourd'hui il suffit de regarder les
enquêtes d'opinion pouvoir que les
questions sont réelles et profondes et
les inquiétudes réelles et profondes
si on dit à ces millions de français
c'est à prendre ou à laisser
alors il ya beaucoup de probabilités
qu'il dise on laisse et c'est absolument
fondées parce qu' il est impossible de
considérer qu'une compétition à
l'intérieur d'un parti ou d'un camp
résume l'élection présidentielle mais
françois bayrou 8 un certain nombre de
gens autour de françois fillon dit ça
mais françois fillon le dit lui même il
l'a dit avait pas un projet pour les
primaires n'est pas un projet pour la
présidentielle il n'a pas bougé d'un
iota et bien je le revendique
je ne doute pas qu'ils réfléchissent à
partir de ce que les français et à cet
instant même nous lui disons je veux
vous rappeler souvent là il il a
clairement dit hier qu'il ne le ferait
pas vous aviez évoqué à propos de son
projet c'était il ya quelques semaines
un projet des centres et c'était votre
votre mot s'il ne paierait pas de
mouvement est ce qu il ne
vous personnellement est ce que vous
vous souvenez de ce grand discours de
philippe séguin y en a eu plusieurs tirs
ont marqué philippe séguin quand il a
dit circulez al'approche de l'élection
présidentielle de 1995 l'on pensait que
la ville de tétouan balladur et c'est là
qu'il n' ya rien à voir
il paraît que l'élection ne va pas avoir
lieu eh bien c'est exactement la même
chose aujourd'hui si on dit aux français
tout a été décidé par la primaire de ce
camp eh bien les français vont
considérer que d'une certaine manière on
porte atteinte à ce que doit être le
débat présidentiel le débat présidentiel
n'est pas le débat d'un camp et donc
c'est pour cette raison que je dis que
françois fillon serait à mon sens
modestement bien inspiré de réfléchir à
la différence qu'il ya entre le candidat
d'un camp et celui qui veut être
président de tout un pays donc à ce
stade
aujourd'hui vous ne soutenez pas sa
candidature non je suis libre facile de
laterrière donc la question à ce stade
j'ai dit depuis le premier jour que je
n'étais pas engagé par les résultats de
cette primaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je n'y ai pas participé parce
que je considère que ma liberté de
citoyen eh bien elle n'est pas à l'être
elle n'a pas à être amoindrie ou
diminuée par une compétition de parti
politique à laquelle je n'appartiens pas
françois fillon qui en marge de ses
voeux hier a réagi aux critiques que
vous aviez misé fortement la semaine
dernière quand ils avaient revendiqué sa
chrétienté
il est je le cite en tout cas il est
repris par la presse bayrou ne manque
pas d'air il est ridicule il a maintes
fois revendiqué sur les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes ridicule ce sont ses mots qui
lui sont prêtés ce sont des ambiances
comme ça voilà donc moi c'est viril
ce sont des sujets qui méritent que on
s'arrête une seconde pour y réfléchir
françois fillon c'est absolument ce que
je vais dire mais il fait semblant
naturellement parce que c'est le jeu
mais cependant pour clarifier les choses
1 lorsqu'on est interrogé sur le sujet
de la religion il est naturel et normal
qu'on dise ce qu'on mais est ce qu'on
croit je n'y ai jamais manqué mais
lorsqu'il s'agit de transformer une
conviction religieuse en position
politique
alors là on manque aux principes qui
sont les principes de notre pays depuis
deux siècles la religion quelle qu'elle
soit ça n'est pas ça n'a pas à être une
étiquette ça n'a pas à être une
idéologie et cantonais interrogé sur la
sécu est bien le fait qu' on est telle
ou telle conviction religieuse n'a rien
à voir avec le projet comporte vous
comprenez la différence 7 cette
séparation que la france a constamment
fait entre la politique l'état et la
conviction religieuse quelle que soit la
religion ou l'absence de religion mais
salez-les vous l'aviez vous avez eu
l'occasion de lire françois bayrou mais
les mots qui lui sont rapportés ce matin
dans la presse montre en tout cas que le
dialogue entre vous êtes encore à bâtir
vous voyez la mairesse vous voyez un mot
de la branche 0 il ya quinze jours
parlons de vous même temps que de la
presse il ya d'abba écouter quand même
c'est votre métier
il ya un métier très vite dix jours et
s'était repris abondamment sur votre
antenne y avait des il y avait un
article dans un journal qui disait
l'accord secret le canard enchaîné vous
l'avez vous l'avez en tout cas vous
accédiez essayons d'être aussi objectifs
qu'on peut l'être
alors soyons objectifs sur un autre
candidat à la présidentielle emmanuel
macron qui se trouve en allemagne on l'a
écouté tout à l'heure dans le journal de
8 heures qui s'affiche européens qui
revendiquent des valeurs de progrès qui
refuse de se classer à gauche
finalement ça y est ce que le centre n'a
pas trouvé son candidat eh bien écoutez
le centre va va dans les semaines qui
viennent
en tout cas cette partie importante du
centre que je représente va dans les
semaines qui viennent
sans précipitation dire ce qu'il en
pense moi je j'ai deux interrogations
sur emmanuel macron la première c'est à
dire que le centre va se prononcer sur
la candidature d'emmanuel manon n'ont
pas du tout fait fait pas semblant de
comptes de ne pas comprendre il faut
clarifier les choses et donc 1
est-ce qu'il est armé pour être
président de la république la
responsabilité présidentielle c'est pas
tout à fait une responsabilité politique
ordinaire et deuxièmement quel est son
projet pour l'instant sur ces deux
interrogations pour moi je n'ai pas de
réponse de réponse afficher ou et
affirmée est ce qu'il n'est pas
aujourd'hui finalement ce que vous aurez
rien rêvé d'être
brice hortefeux la semaine dernière
disait finalement macron stains bayrou
des temps modernes est ce que c'est pas
un bayrou 2.0 est ce qu'il n'est pas la
vision moderne du centre
je ne sais pas ce que moderne ne veut
dire lorsqu'il s'agit d'incarner un
projet politique qui est différent du
projet de la droite et du projet de la
gauche car le centre contrairement à ce
que vous croyez
ce n'est pas un entre deux ce n'est pas
un ni ni
le centre c'est un projet politique à
part entière qui a cessé axe et qui
depuis longtemps veut proposer aux
français une alternative et donc de ce
point de vue là on va voir le jour
emmanuel pas qu'on dira ce qu'il veut
faire
quels sont les axes quels sont les choix
qu'il va faire à ce moment là on saura
si ces idées qui sont celles du centre
c'est la même chose avec françois fillon
sont compatibles ou ne le sont pas mais
françois bayrou on peut attendre de
savoir ce que emmanuel macron veut faire
on peut attendre de voir quels candidats
socialistes va sortir des primaires
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous empêche
de vous décider à être candidat on ne
comprend pas très franchement puisque
vous parlez d'être clair il faut que
vous essayez de comprendre je suis
abreuvé les efforts mais il faut je suis
raide et libre
est-ce que je suis satisfait par l'offre
politique qui est aujourd'hui proposé
comme des millions de français non je ne
reconnais pas dans l'offre politique
proposée les attentes qui sont les
nôtres donc savons différentes parties
du pays est donc un leurre l'isi et donc
je ne suis comment dire je ne suis sous
pression de personne j'ai le temps et je
suis libre et vous n'avez pas le temps
de sa ccsa résidentiel cédant 3 c'est
votre jugement j'ai il faut l'exposé et
via jeunes en finance je vous proposerai
de lire le livre qui va sortir au
lendemain des primaires de la gauche je
viendrais volontiers en parlait ici et
qui exposera ce projet qui est un projet
différent qui n'est pas seulement le
mien qui est celui de ce grand courant
politique qui a 10 millions de personnes
qui lui appartiennent et qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans ce qu'on lui offre
aujourd'hui donc on sera fixé dans
quelques semaines un mot simplement ce
qui se passe aux etats unis on a appris
ce matin les renseignements américains
ont informé le président sortant barack
obama et le prochain président donald
trump qui l'avait été espionnée par les
russes que les russes détenait des
documents compromettants sur lui on peut
faire confiance à la russie aujourd'hui
je fais la distinction entre la russie
et l'administration poutine et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je plaide pour que
au contraire d'un certain nombre de
courants politiques français nombreux on
prenne de la distance non pas avec la
russie avec qui il faut parler mais avec
monsieur poutine et sa manière
d'intervenir au delà de ses frontières
sur la politique du monde
la tv lire la manière différence
fondamentale entre vous et françois
fillon c'est une différence fondamentale
et je la revendique
la france n'a pas à être en situation de
trop grande proximité avec des
responsables politiques d'autres pays
surtout quand ils ont des attitudes qui
ne correspondent pas à l'idée que nous
nous faisons des relations
internationales ne peut pas discuter
avec vladimir poutine pas ce que vous
dites les russes oui poutine non mais
c'est lui le président je n'ai pas dit
non
j'ai dit indépendance j'ai dit garder
suffisamment de distance pour que votre
jugement soit un jugement libre pour que
vous ne soyez pas automatiquement
entraîné dans le sillage d'attitude et
de pratiques qui leur semblent pas à ce
que la france doit exiger merci françois
bayrou est revenu ce matin
pardon sur europe 1 demain c'est patrick
weil 1 qui sera votre invité fabien on
parlera laïcité histoire immigration qui
sont au coeur des projets de très
nombreux candidats
merci fabien à demain
[Musique]